this next story is sort of the perfect
epitome of
everything that is donald trump
according to the former department of
homeland security
chief of staff miles taylor donald trump
floated the idea of swapping puerto rico
for greenland in order to get rid of
some of those
poor puerto ricans from dirty puerto
rico
yeah this combines like three or four
different stories so
first of course is trump's obvious
disregard for puerto rico we saw this
during hurricane response in the past
you might remember donald trump
showing up in puerto rico and shooting
rolls of paper towels like basketballs
then there's the idea of the [ __ ]
country which
mostly are countries with brown people
and then there's the idea of trump being
interested in acquiring greenland which
is something that came up
i don't know if it was six months ago or
12 months ago just time feels so strange
at this point
and lastly kind of tying it all together
is donald trump's completely deranged
worldview
his delusions of grandeur his narcissism
his complete lack of empathy so
let's first go to the tape here is miles
taylor former department of homeland
security
chief of staff telling the story himself
on msnbc
tear gas at the border et cetera i'm
wondering what is the most in the
conversations you're involved in
disturbing idea or thought or discussion
that you heard from president trump that
is sort of resonating and sitting with
you still today
we could probably go on for days about
that although i'm going to tell you one
thing that just popped into my head
howie
there was a time when of course we were
spending a lot of our days
down in puerto rico after the hurricanes
uh wreak devastation down there
u.s virgin islands uh and other places
there was a trip that we made down there
in august of 2018 and i remember before
we went
the president said something and your
viewers are going to be somewhat
familiar with this the president's
talked before
about wanting to purchase greenland but
one time before we went down he told us
not only did he want to purchase
greenland he actually said he wanted to
see if we could sell puerto rico could
we swap puerto rico
for greenland because in his words uh
puerto rico was dirty
and the people were poor these are
americans hallie
uh and we don't talk about our fellow
americans that way
so this is really pretty wild and
completely unconscionable and really
something to contend with
it has to be an anecdote for some kind
of hall of fame although i don't know
what we would be commemorating in this
hall of fame it wouldn't be anything
good but it seems like that anecdote is
historic in some sense
and i'm reminded of what michelle obama
told us
during her dnc speech on the first night
of the democratic national convention
monday which was
if you think things couldn't possibly
get any worse
they can and they will if we don't make
a change this election now
merely as a thought experiment if puerto
rico
got to become part of denmark the way
greenland is part of denmark now
puerto ricans might actually be better
off because my guess is
denmark wouldn't do to puerto rico or
neglect puerto rico
in the way that donald trump has
neglected puerto rico so from the
standpoint of the puerto rican people
it may be interesting to them to
actually become part of denmark but
of course this is completely crazy in
every sense
and it's very funny to hear the right
continue to insist that latino voters
are just
they're on the verge they're so close of
becoming republicans
and abandoning the democratic party then
you hear this
and it's very hard to fathom that that's
the case and
of course cubans are the most
conservative
latino group in the united states other
than cubans
there is very little republicanism among
latino
voters puerto ricans dominicans
mexicans argentinians so on and so forth
and
and then by the way everybody who talked
about
we need a business person running the
country like a business
this is what you get this is what you
get when you have someone who says
if a piece of my business isn't
interesting if a
piece of my business is a loss leader if
it's not
profitable or whatever let me see if i
can find some sucker to offload it to
or sell it to and that's how you get a
president who says maybe i could trade
puerto rico for greenland
um we i used the term earlier we we are
reaping what we've sown
and that is exactly what you see in this
story one of our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman